[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con como si no
fuera suficiente además del pico de
contagio de kobe 19 que deja a miles de
víctimas y contagios india frente hace
frente ahora a una nueva amenaza
el llamado hongo negro que deja cerca de
9.000 casos la escasez de medicamentos y
también la falta de infraestructura
médica juega en contra de esta situación
en ese país asiático para conversar
sobre este tema saludamos al doctor
oscar franco él es director del
instituto de medicina preventiva y
social de berna se encuentra en la
ciudad de leiden en los países bajos y
está con nosotros para ampliar este tema
gracias doctor por estar con nosotros y
ya lo decíamos hay una especie de nueva
epidemia que ha sido declarada en índia
por esta infección que ha sido
denominada como hongo negro porque tiene
lugar en este momento esa enfermedad
cuando estamos en pleno pico de la
pandemia
si en primer lugar que es el hongo negro
el hongo negro es es también conocido
una infección que se llama mucormicosis
es una infección producida por un hongo
de la familia de los hongos mu corales y
se le llama hongo negro por la
pigmentación el color que tiene y
también las lesiones que produce tienen
ese color usted es un hongo que vive
normalmente en las plantas en el suelo y
que normalmente en india se reportaban
unos 500 casos al año y ahora mismo
hemos visto casi 9.000 en unas cuantas
semanas y hemos visto como algo que se
reporta por primera vez en delhi en el
estado de maharashtra ha pasado ahora
mismo a declararse epidemia en 29 de los
36 estados y territorios que constituyen
el país asiático doctor porque ataca
particularmente en esta instancia a las
personas que se han recuperado del cob y
19 esta es una infección que es rara
pero siempre ha estado presente como
usted lo dice porque está desatada en
este momento
ahora mismo hoy en día vive una segunda
ola del virus que es devastadora ha
afectado a muchísima gente y se ha
empezado a reportar esta infección en
personas que se están recuperando unos
10 o 15 días después de estar en
recuperación
esto se ha relacionado con el uso
indiscriminado y de altas dosis de
esteroides que se han considerado que
podrían ayudar y también se ha
relacionado con el uso de unificadores
en la administración de oxígeno a
hipótesis acerca del uso indiscriminado
de otros medicamentos como el zinc u
otros antibióticos pero se está
evaluando ahora mismo doctor frank o hay
algunas personas con condiciones de
salud particulares que tengan mayor
riesgo para contraer este llamado
hongo negro y también quisiera
preguntarle qué complicaciones puede
traer entonces esta enfermedad
la mayoría de las personas en las que se
están reportando esta infección en
indias tienden a ser hombres tienden a
ser diabéticos que tienen bajo control
de su azúcar en la sangre esta infección
antes de este color de la epidemia el
coronavirus de la pandemia que estamos
viviendo se reportaba en pacientes
diabéticos son pacientes que decidieron
un trasplante o en pacientes que están
en inmunosuprimidos por algún
tratamiento entonces se considera como
una infección oportunista toma ventaja
cuando las defensas se baja lo que
produce sinusitis dolor de cabeza una
superación de color negro que sale por
la nariz afecta a los ojos los senos
paranasales pueden pasar al cerebro y
puede afectar el pulmón también entonces
estas son las complicaciones que pueden
producir en el 50% puede ser fatal y
puede llegar y puede tener mucho riesgo
y generar una deformación que permanece
en las personas que sufran esta
infección importante entonces hombres y
diabéticos serían una del segmento clave
para el desarrollo de esta enfermedad
doctor cuál es el tratamiento entonces
para atacar
esta enfermedad denominada como el hongo
lo negro y cuáles son esos primeros
síntomas que debemos tener en cuenta
si estos primeros síntomas después en un
dolor de cabeza una saturación una
sinusitis que avanza y se complica muy
rápidamente y puede pasar al cerebro el
tratamiento vemos que hasta el 80% de
los pacientes con este hongo están
requiriendo una operación para remover
ese tejido necrótico gangrena que es de
ese color negro que por lo que se llama
uno negro y puede requerir que se se
quite la nariz o o el ojo o muchas veces
en la mandíbula se ha retirado la
mandíbula completamente o parcialmente
el tratamiento tiene que hacerse lo más
pronto posible apenas se sospecha del
estado en yo está aconsejando a los
pacientes que busquen ayudar lo antes
posible y requiere un tratamiento con
antimicóticos con un tratamiento como la
foteli cinabe que ahora mismo pues
también está muy escasa en todo el día
doctor frank o muchas gracias por
explicar este tema de importancia a la
audiencia de france 24 y atentos
entonces a lo que suceda en india en
torno al desarrollo de esta enfermedad
denominada como el logro negro ustedes
muchas gracias por la sintonía siga con
nosotros
[Música]